[Music]
we do this by doing two sides at
measurements we need after that we go
right at the bottom and then just slide
it right through after that we do it
from the top and then I sort of just go
like this and that's the block for the
igloo
yeah so when you bring the animal back
from the land you'd bring it back out
here and what's next we usually just
store it up but once we catch a caribou
we usually take the fresh meat and cook
some of it okay and the rest we just
store it up right in here in this meat
sack wow that's a lot
yeah can feed a lot of people with that
yeah I can feed the whole entire town
the majority of the meat that your
family would consume is stuff that
you've gotten here out on the land yeah
it's actually pretty much healthier
because the store-bought food are
processed and we don't really know where
they came from and what they put in the
processed meat because once we catch the
animal and use their meat we actually
really respect the animal when it comes
to hunting it's like being able to be
free and so we've seen the meat here
what happens to the skins keep them for
our sleds why is it important to have
skins on the sleds so that would be a
lot softer once were on it or so that we
don't usually really damage the sled
we usually store them in a sack so that
it wouldn't be buried under all these
snow we have
muscat skin on the top because we
usually use it the most since it's more
soft and more durable than the caribou
skins so this is the best kind of fur
skin to use on the kama ticks yes Wow
underneath here are caribou skin they're
pretty much like the musk ox skin but
they're thinner and harder but what
about for example with the caribou with
the head and the antlers what happens to
that part of the animal and how do you
use that sometimes we use analysts so we
can make a fishing line you can make
actually a fishing line with the antlers
from the caribou yeah we can actually
make them like a fishing rod this one
here has cut the ice sizzle and it's
pretty basic and right here's the blade
where we actually hit the ice with the
rest is just completely just for
handling so we can hold it and hit the
ice with it let me show you another tool
this is actually called the school
that's what I call it it seems to take
out the ice that's broken inside the
hole so the first step would be to break
up the ice with this then it's left with
sort of a hole with all that chunky
slush and ice yeah and then this is what
you'd use to get that out yes sometimes
the ice is too thick to put our hand in
and just scoop it up with our hand
but Robin it's usually minus 30 or more
here you're telling me that you would
put your bare hand into the water and
take the ice out with your bare hands
yeah and to me it's kind of soothing
it's not too cold for you no it's not
good
it's sort of like a cold summer Dean